so let us first review the steady state
behavior of Markov chains consider again
the following example this chain has
some recurrent states some transient
states and a single recurrent class so
for example state 9 is recurrent state 3
is recurrent state 5 is recurrent and
why are the recurrent because whenever
you are in 9 no matter where you go
there is always a way to come back you
can go to 3 and come back or 5 and come
back and actually this is a recurrent
class and this is a recurrent class
because all these recurrent states
communicate between each other what
about the other states where they are
not recurrent so for example state 1
once you are here there is a possibility
that you go there and you will never
come back so it cannot be recommence
with transient what about 4 4 also has
the possibility at one point to go there
and then from there they will never come
back so 4 is also transient as 4 - no
matter where it goes
well you was gonna reach or touch a
transient state so by definition it will
be also transient so they are three
transient states and 3 recurrent states
also this recurrent class is not
periodic so it's a periodic and why is
it not periodic well here there is a
simple way to tell we have the existence
of a self transition probability and
that's enough to show that this
recurrent class is not periodic so this
is one of the nicest possible Markov
chains in the sense that they have the
following property the probability that
you find yourself at some particular
state J at time n when n is very large
converges to a steady state value that
we denote by PI of J there are two
aspects to this property first the limit
exists so the priority of stage J does
not fluctuate it said also something
the long run and furthermore that
property is not affected by I now if we
don't know where the change started and
we want to know the unconditional
probability of being in state J in the
long run when n is large then either we
are given an initial distribution of
these states or we can choose any
initial distribution for example we can
assume that all initial states are
equally likely or any other type of
distributions and then you can condition
over all the initial states use the top
priority theorem and you are going to
get the same answer PI of J in the limit
let's see how to do that so this is the
summation of all I so you condition on
that state I so it's our IJ of n times
the initial priority distribution of
your choosing so this is the top
priority theorem now in the limit when n
goes to infinity this goes to PI of J in
epinet of I so you can take this
expression the limit and take it out of
the summation and then you have the
summation of P of X 0 equals 1 these are
probabilities so they sum to 1 so in the
end you have that converges to PI of J
so the conditional probability given the
initial state is in the limit the same
as the unconditional probability when n
is large and in that sense D tells us
that X of N and X of 0 are approximately
independent they become independent in
the limit as n goes to infinity so if
the Markov chain has run for a long time
and you are asked the question where is
the chain now then your answer should be
I don't know it's random but it's going
to be in a particular
J with that particular probability PI of
J so in that sense the steady-state
probabilities of valuable information so
how do we compute them well for
transient states like these there are
zero so PI of 1 is 0 PI over 2 is 0 and
PI of 4 is 0 and why is that well if
your initial state where one of the
states here the priority of being in
here is zero no matter what but even if
you started here initially in one of
these states you might for a while
fluctuate and turn around like that but
eventually after a finite amount of time
you will go to that class and never come
back to one so in the long run the
probability of finding yourself in state
1 will be 0 and this is the same for 2 &
4
now how do we calculate these well for
these states in the reckoning class we
compute them by solving a linear system
of equations which are called the
balance equation these together with an
extra condition the normalization
equation here has to be satisfied
because these are probabilities and they
have to sum up to 1 and we have seen
that the system of n plus 1 equation
provide a unique solution to this kind
of system for the recurrent class so you
would apply that to that recurrent class
and in that gate example you have three
states so you would choose M equals 3
for that example and you would solve
this system to get the PI J's now what
if we had multiple recurrent classes
consider this chain it is an expanded
version of the previous one with
additional states some of these are
recurrent and one is transient but now
we have two recurrent classes and that
was our one class so plus one
and now we have a second recurrent class
last year so what happens in the long
run when you have situations like that
well in the long run if you start from
here you're going to stay here and in
some sense the study of that recurrent
class is the same as the study of that
recurrent class and in order to find the
steady-state probabilities of these
states assuming that you're starting in
one of these will be exactly the same as
before so you would use the same system
with M equals 3 here now if you had
started here instead again this is the
recurrent class and you have M equals
two states here and in order to find
what is the steady state probabilities
of the two states you could use the same
kind of result here but you apply it
with M equals 2 in isolation so you you
just concentrate on that if on the other
hand your Markov chain started from here
for example for that specific example
you are guaranteed that the next
transition you had up here and then you
can do the same thing as before we still
know that this steady-state priority of
8 will be 0 and 0 and 0 and 0 now what
would happen if you started from here
from one of these states well again for
a while you might travel throughout this
system here but eventually you're gonna
move away from that and you will either
go through a transition going into that
recurrent class by this transition or by
this transition and once you are in
there essentially the chain will remain
there and so you do the same calculation
as before and if on the other hand you
transition away from that class and
arrived in this recurrent class then you
would apply the result that you had here
so in some sense conditional on the fact
that you left the states and you arrived
there in that conditional world you can
isolate yourself and really solve the
problem for that class and the same from
that class now of course this
raises the question if I start from here
how do I know whether I'm going to get
here or here well we don't know it's
random so we will be interested in
calculating the probabilities that
eventually you end up here versus here
and this is something that we are going
to do towards the end of today's lecture